what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with fall of X and the return
of the Phoenix Force now this all takes
place in the Gan gray comic and we're
actually going to cover the final issue
because honestly the other ones are
really hard to follow if you don't know
the history of Gan gray but it's a lot
easier to follow if we do this one
because then I can make it all make
sense so the thing to know is that at
the very beginning of the fall of X
storyline Jean Gray was basically killed
off right like she was one of the
mutants who died we know she did a
couple things here and there but in the
aftermath of her death Jean Gray was
actually transported to the white hot
room why is that so in Marvel Comics
it's been established since really
Phoenix end song and Phoenix War song
some old school comics from back in the
day that when Jean Gray dies she won't
actually go to the realm of mistress
death that she will go to the white hot
room and the reason for that is the
Phoenix Force exists in the white hot
room and the Phoenix force is kind of
like this omniversal concept meaning the
Phoenix Force only exists as one entity
throughout the entirety of the
Multiverse much like the Living Tribunal
Oblivion different things like that but
different people in different universes
can be a host for a portion of the
Phoenix Force's power but Gan gray among
every being in the Multiverse is the one
perfect host for the Phoenix so it's
almost kind of like she's going home to
where she's supposed to be at but the
kicker about all this is that because
she's here what had happened over the
first three issues of the story
is she had come across these simal
moments in her life the original Phoenix
Saga kind of the Prelude to the Phoenix
Saga when she was first given the
Phoenix Force itself that in that story
she had chosen for wolver rain to have
it instead of her and then eventually
Cyclops gets it and she had done this
because the question she had existing in
the Phoenix Force after her death was if
I had done things differently how would
things have transpired was it a decision
that I made now the reason why she takes
this kind of logic onto herself is
because when she was the host of The
Phoenix at the full height of her power
the white Phoenix of the crown as she
was called she was astronomically
powerful her power I would argue rivaled
that of the Living Tribunal there really
isn't a onetoone comparison there really
isn't an instance where like she fights
the Living Tribunal we kind of have to
do what power scalers do and sort of
cook the books in order to come to a
conclusion there but the fact remains
here that she was incredibly capable so
the choices she made and the decisions
that she made very much impacted not
just the main Marvel Universe but any
possible alternate realities that
existed out there and that's why all
these versions of her immediately start
attacking her and are just exceedingly
angry at her one of the things that
happens here is that as she's talking to
one of ourselves and really talking more
to the Phoenix Force than anything else
it seems a little bit Cloak and Dagger
but one of the things she says is she
says why are all of you so angry it
can't simply just be because we're dead
we've been dead before and one of them
simply says don't you get it we're
figments of your past figments of your
nightmares products of imaginary stories
you've been telling yourself none of
this is real but then I was never real
except here in the white hot room
everything is real in its own way and
Jean asked the question what do you mean
and that's when they kind of reference
what she's been doing so far which is in
some ways kind of re structuring and
reorganizing the white hot room to
create what are in effect pocket
realities literally what Jean's been
doing here is she's been using the power
she has which this is an astronomical
level of power but she's been using this
power she has to kind of reconstruct
reality to make it look like events from
the past and then changing those just to
see what happens this is no different
than someone like the Living Tribunal or
whoever it is creating a universe out of
thin air and and then changing things
that happen in that Universe over the
time of that Universe just to see what
takes place she's literally messing with
reality but not just toying with it it's
like you a full adult being given Legos
right for you it's Child's Play it's
just kind of a thing that you're doing
that's what's really so crazy here but
one of the things that happens is that
one of the Phoenix's tell her you use
those memories to forge together a
terrible future you brought the Phoenix
into it you made me what I am and
everybody died so this is kind of her
referencing the reality she created
where wolver rain got the Phoenix force
and then literally Cyclops got the
Phoenix Force but because of the chaos
that followed during that time in effect
everybody on Earth was destroyed right
now this could also be a reference where
what if the Phoenix Force never really
became sane after becoming the dark
Phoenix and wiped out the entirity of
the universe it's a really cool what if
story right like what if the dark
Phoenix killed the Marvel Universe it's
pretty Prett awesome it's pretty dope
it's old but it's really really good but
it's one of those things where the
Phoenix itself is really what's
communicating with Jean here because
what the Phoenix says is it says you
should have trusted me you are mad at
yourself and so what's cool is Jean says
no I needed to consider the
ramifications to think things through
that's why she's kind of going through
and creating these different realities
because by passing The Phoenix force on
to somebody else and rejecting the
Phoenix Force for self even entertaining
the idea the Phoenix itself sees this as
an insult right the very fact that you
wouldn't trust me the very fact that you
consider there was a possibility that I
the Phoenix Force this sum total of all
life that has ever currently does and
will ever exist in the Multiverse that
you would believe that I was wrong that
I chose incorrectly what huous what
arrogance for you to believe that and
that's why these kind of fax similes of
of Jee are appearing it's all the
Phoenix force and it's almost kind of
taunting her it's angry at her but it's
also trying to get her to understand
what's really going on here because
literally Jean says maybe it would have
been better if it was someone else that
was in charge of the Phoenix Force maybe
it wasn't all up to me but that's where
the statement's made whereas in reality
the Phoenix had hidden your body and
while you healed it took on your aspect
in your name it destroyed the darbar's
world unfortunate but not your fault it
rode your anger your need as far as was
possible until your true will asserted
itself and stopped it you died of course
now what's being referenced here this is
a very important thing what's being
referenced here is the Phoenix and the
dark Phoenix sagas in Marvel Comics so
for those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that and this is one of
the reasons why I wanted to cover this
issue and then just kind of hearken back
to things in Jean Grace's history when
Jean first became the Phoenix she had
simply just achieved a crazy power boost
and it was really cool right she shot
out of the water in Jamaica Bay I am
Phoenix right like just one of the most
iconic moments not really in just marvel
history but like comic book history
right following the conclusion of the
Phoenix Saga Mastermind also known as
Jason winguard from the hellfire club
had basically taken Gan and then used
his power to manipulate the five senses
to trick her into believing she was on
like this Victorian Airship right that
whole thing but what ended up happening
is that in order to break the nection
between Jean Gray and the love of her
life Cyclops Mastermind uses powers to
trick jean into thinking Cyclops had
been killed and in fact the exact
opposite happened that despite the
Phoenix Force being this incredible
source of power it had never experienced
rage it had never experienced the
feeling of loss or love or anything like
that so quite literally it went insane
with emotion and so what's being talked
about here the Phoenix Force had hidden
your body and took on your aspect and
all that kind of stuff that at the end
of the dark Phoenix Saga originally Gan
gray had momentarily regained control of
the Phoenix Force which had essentially
taken over her mind and was just driven
by Madness Jee ultimately flew herself
you know out there and then basically
sacrificed her own life and Jean was
supposed to die because of the
popularity of Jean Gray and the Phoenix
and dark Phoenix sagas and all that kind
of stuff Marvel ended up having to bring
her back from the dead the funny thing
is it started off with Chris claremon as
a bluff gym shooter called it then made
him kill Jean so actually it was a
writer who came up with the idea it
wasn't done by Marvel editorial for
those of you guys who always believe
that Marvel writers can do no wrong so
the thing here is that what had happened
in that follow-up story is it was
actually in the Fantastic 4 they had
gone down to the bottom of Jamaica Bay
they had found a cocoon down there when
they brought it to the X-Men and it was
opened up Jean Gray was inside and
that's when you got the big Revelation
that basically said that the Phoenix as
it appeared was never actually Gene it
had just taken on her physical form and
the real Gene was healing down in the
bottom of Jamaica Bay that's an
important thing to understand with
regards to her history but that's what's
being referenced here right and that's
why when the Phoenix says but that
wasn't the end not by a long shot they
found your true body cocooned Beneath
the Sea and awakened you that's what
she's referencing right and she says you
are returned to Scott all was restored
how is that terrible and the response of
Jean is because of what came afterward
impulsive arrogance didn't work so I
tried Logic the response of the Phoenix
and set them up to die not everyone just
your dearest loves and that's where
another personality chimes in and says
from that perspective the reality was so
much kinder to you anyway surely you
haven't forgotten about me as much as
you all would rather and that's when Jee
realizes this is meline Pryor now for
those of you guys who don't know about
meline prior she was a really cool
character in Marvel Comics now she's
boring as hell she sucks but the cool
thing about meline is that the villain
Mr Sinister had come to the realization
that if Gan gray and cyclops ever had a
child their child would be
astronomically powerful and while they
technically never really did it did kind
of happen in Age of Apocalypse that's
where you get Nate Gray from the 1990s
that ridiculously op character X-Man as
some people call him but meline prior
was a clone right she was the attempt of
sinister to clone gray and then try to
initiate a coupling between meline prior
and cyclops the funny thing is behind
the scenes this was supposed to be the
end Jean Gray was dead done gone forever
mine prior was supposed to marry Cyclops
and then literally ride off into the
sunset and cyclops was never going to be
seen or heard from again in marel comics
such as it was Jean Gray ultimately
returned she joined xfactor Cyclops took
off he joined xfactor as well but meline
prior initially didn't have any powers
didn't even really have any life and
that's why Jee refers to meline as my
clunk right meline says Mr sinister's
broodmare mother of the mutant Nathan
Christopher renamed cable a blank slate
with so many possibilities because
meline prior in Cyclops did produce a
child that's the person that you all
know is cable that's where he came from
right and it's one of those things
because she ultimately ended up going
insane meline prior did and that's when
she became the goblin Queen right it's
really cool the way that is put together
ruler of demons new improved and in this
reality transm moded given free Reign
Over a techno organically transformed
world I was mad you were mad we lost our
tempers and things got a bit out of hand
the end of the world very cathartic but
maybe a bit too much even for me and so
she's kind of referencing this sort of
restructured reality that Gina created
where what if something else hadn't
happened right like what if the whole
situation with the original Inferno
event from back in the 80s
what if that never took place and so
it's kind of the funny thing because the
question here that's posed by Jean Gray
is would your life have been better
right because had I never become the
Phoenix force and had I initiated a
circumstance whereby I had never died or
any number of those things right you
never would have come to life you never
would have had any kind of a life you
never would have lived at all right
that's why the questions asked no
Kingdom to rule in Hell never alive
never feeling no Scott no baby Nathan no
nothing and that's when the statement's
made now you're getting it right and
that's where things get cool because we
have fine Minds as Minds go but that's
not our greatest asset heart depth of
feeling that's what called The Phoenix
to us love is what you're all about I
have other priorities Inferno happened
For Better or For Worse it's not the
worst thing I've had to face life is a
process however you are created we all
learn even you even me and that's when
the Phoenix really begins to kind of
step in and says that's better right
you've been creating worlds to prove
that you had no choice nightmare tales
about how we you and I brought death and
destruction how you were damned if you
did damned if you didn't all paths lead
to death is this really the story you
wanted to tell yourself your dreams so
much more terrible than even this
reality because the truth about Jean's
character is even after she returned
following the events of dark Phoenix and
been forced to come to terms with her
actions she always blamed herself right
anything that ever happened with the
Phoenix Force she always blamed herself
when Rachel Summers became the Phoenix
she blamed herself right all these
things she blamed herself about because
in her mind she was the first host for
the Phoenix she's the one who opened the
door she's the one that allowed the
Phoenix to basically set up shop in the
main Marvel Universe and anything to do
with that level of energy that came
after any loss of life any of that was
all on her shoulders so that's when she
starts to remember because at the very
beginning of all this she didn't
remember anything right but then she
starts to remember everything that had
happened the Hellfire go the party orgus
his attack on the mutant population all
those things that Jean tried to protect
them and save them but ultimately she
failed and so at the end of it all she
simply says why didn't you come to me
right you as the Phoenix why didn't you
Bond yourself with me and in fact that's
the question a lot of fans have been
asking where's the Phoenix Force been
through all of this right Jean is the
host for the Phoenix why hasn't she
become the Phoenix yet and you get this
amazing response right how could I I'm
as dead now as you are like you I only
exist here a Nexus between all Phoenix
hosts and our Eternal Flame I'm bits in
pieces inactive the white hot room is
the heart of the Phoenix and it is
broken when you woke up here you asked
what did I do wrong the answer is
nothing why do you think I encourage
those terrible images where when you
could have changed things everything
went wrong what did you think I was
trying to tell you and the response of
Gan is that my instinctive choices were
right that my impulse was true and the
response of the Phoenix is you
ultimately did all you could you did the
best you could given the circumstance
that you were in and the power that you
had but the reality here is that there
were other forces at play and this is
one of the best things one of the
reasons why I love Lise Simonson when
she writes these stories because Lis
Simonson's old school right Chris
Claremont Roy Thomas John burn old
school right like back in the 80s right
70s 80s Marvel Comics old school because
she loved in any of the stories that she
ever had a hand in she loved to invoke
real world elements right because who
Among Us has ever been in a situation
where despite having done everything
that we could we just felt like we could
have done more there's no evidence to
indicate that and in fact all evidence
is to the contrary there's nothing more
that we could have done but for one
reason or another past traumas whatever
the case is that we ultimately just
Hammer ourselves with this philosophy
that like we should have done more we
could have done more but like what more
could you have done you did everything
that you could there was only so much
that could happen here and so what jean
comes to the realization of is no matter
what choices we make in the end death
claims us all and the response of the
Phoenix is but not us at least not yet
not completely and that's when Gan
chimes in and says we're not alone here
and there's one more thing we can do
shall we do it together now this is
important because if you guys are
following our coverage of fall of X The
Immortal X-Men are in the white hot room
those 250,000 mutants that were sent
away from kakoa by Xavier right he was
forced to do that at the hands of orcus
the group attacking mutants everywhere
that they can find them they ended up in
the white hot room we don't know exactly
how they ended up there but we know that
they did that's what Jean's talking
about because she's been here the whole
time so for those of you guys who are
following Immortal X and literally in
the last video that we covered they're
traveling through the white hot room and
Jean's just suddenly there this is the
reason why she's been there the entire
time she was just over in that area over
there right like if the white hot Rumors
in the United States everybody in
Immortal X-Men was in New York Gan gray
was in Missouri somewhere right that's
kind of how this this works and so once
she's there she's not really there as a
physical presence they can't actually
see her but she is there in a kind of
spiritual form and of course she sort of
makes an off-handed remark that like
apocalypse being apocalypse right he is
a manifestation of the white hot room
it's not the actual apocalypse but he's
doing what he does which is just like
going after people and so on and so
forth right and then she sees Hope
Summer and she says like poor hope it's
up to her now welcome to the white hot
room now an important thing to
understand about Hope Summers and people
who have been reading Marvel for a long
time already know this this is more for
the new folks Hope Summers is a mutant
who was the first mutant born after the
events of House of M when the Scarlet
Witch took away 98% of the mutant
population's Powers because of the fact
that she was taken and rescued by cable
even though she's not related to Jean
and in fact there were theories out
there that she was a reincarnated
version of Jee because Gene had been
dead since Phoenix War song and Phoenix
in song at this point in time that that
turned out to not be the case but
because they bore a striking resemblance
the color of their hair the color of
their eyes cable ended up naming her
hope because she represented Hope For
The Rebirth of the mutant population and
then he named her Summers because that
was his last name he of course took her
on as a kind of daughter but the reality
here is that her ability is to copy the
powers of anybody around around her this
is a massive thing here because we
always assumed this was a byproduct of a
physical person who is walking around
her what this establishes is that all
that really has to happen is the essence
of a person their spiritual form has to
be around hope and then she can
immediately copy their abilities right
and so what Gan says is Hope's basic
power is to mimic the abilities of those
near her there may be something we can
do together one last Gambit and that's
why Gene touches hope and then hope
immediately manifests the Phoenix Force
right like literally takes on this
amazing thing and the question that the
Phoenix asks is did it work and Jean in
a kind of spiritual form watching over
all of this we don't know the answer to
it in fact we'll have to find out in the
newest Immortal X-Men comic which is
kind of funny because this seems to have
more or less spoiled it but the thing
that goes on is jeene says no longer am
I the woman you knew I am fire in life
incarnate now and forever I am Phoenix
and the question is who knows right like
that is something else at least we did
no harm and so the Phoenix says you know
so sure of yourself so arrogant and Jean
says just following my gut but then you
have this moment where Jean makes the
statement you know this isn't over not
for them not for us but what comes next
be it life or death we face it together
so in effect fact what Marvel is telling
us is Gan gray will become the Phoenix
once again how long it'll last we don't
know but I'm excited man because I'll
tell you guys right now white hot like
white Phoenix of the crown Jean Gray she
can take all Commerce and she could
crush pretty much anybody out there the
only exception is probably the beyonders
and maybe the Living Tribunal but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on fall of X make sure you
guys click this link to the playlist and
I will catch you all later peace